here on the Rich Eisen show one of the
good guys in this business and from
Showtime now as opposed to the worldwide
leader when we hung out back in the day
he is al Bernstein good to see you how
great to be here what a why you're steer
so so fantastic it's great to be here
you normally listening on our I listen
now you guys affiliate yeah okay bad 920
so I'm more of a listener I don't get to
see it on television so now here I mean
I do of course have seen it as all good
but I don't get to I don't get to see
the whole grandeur of it great I love
grandeurs what I the way I look at how
did you get involved in boxing how did
you convince me that was interesting
what you're saying you know I wrote a
book on boxing for beginners it was
called I was I was I didn't amateur
boxer and I was writing but I was in
hard news I was in this paper editor so
I wasn't even doing explored hard news
yeah and I was I was the managing editor
of a chain of newspapers and somebody
came to me said we need you to write it
we need a book unboxing and we know
you've boxed and you've written about
boxing you covered it's okay then uh
when ESPN came along in 19 and I covered
fights for boxing Illustrated and Ring
Magazine in places like that ESPN came
along in 1980 and one of their stops was
Chicago and I they I'm one of the
broadcasts they they Tommy Hearns was
struggling with somebody he was
broadcasting they said could you sit in
here because I had helped them on
broadcast and I did they liked what I
did and that was that off you go so what
was the first fight I can tell you the
name of the first fight game is Lola
Tandy and uh Mike Bradley now I'm amazed
I remember it but it's always stuck in
my mind because I'll never forget
sitting there and doing it and saying I
love this I want to do this or I want to
do I want to be broadcast for the rest
of my life well I remember you know the
first fight I covered for ESPN was polo
field more - in Las Vegas with you and
John Saracino and I remember it was my
first exposure to the boxing world in
the boxing the boxing media world and I
just remember sitting there and I'm like
wow that is Bert sugar over there - yes
right right with his hat what yeah
what's your best Bert sugar story oh
gosh first of all Bert
and you know you summon all those
outfits Bert sugar was responsible for
the murder of a thousand rapes he he
would wear these pants that look like
they were the drapes from Sound of Music
remember when she made the drapes into
yeah you know things for the kids and
you know he was any of the Hat and Bert
sugar could drink more than any human
that ever lived and to still function is
really yeah and function you'd be having
conversation with him and you've just
seen him put away I don't know eight
drinks and you're like how are you even
functioning or talking when I first when
I first met Bert I walked up to him and
I'm like introduced him like hi I'm Rich
Eisen I'm working with al Bernstein ah I
know I serious I wanted to drop some
names yeah there you go without
Bernstein no I'm serious and and and
Johnson you know I'm part of the SPN
thing and he says nice to meet you and
I'm like great to see you and I'm great
to see you and your your full regalia
pointing to his entire wardrobe and he
goes come on I look like a goodwill box
grew up on me is what he said with that
wit they took that's what he said he
took that cigar out yes come on it
looked like a goodwill box threw up on
me first Bert was a character you know
interestingly he wrote as many books
about baseball as the Box I did not know
that he was a prolific writer and was a
baseball historian as well and wrote
many books about baseball so he was that
it was a fascinating guy Wolverine who
went to Michigan University in machining
ever knew that about Bert sugar I'm here
- I'm here to help here al yeah yeah no
he was it was Wolverine Wow all right I
want to take a 60-second break come back
and get dive deep into this but I'd
rather fight now what'd you think of it
okay in a fight game guy for for as long
as you have International Boxing Hall of
Fame analyst al Bernstein here on the
Rich Eisen show back in 60 seconds
without
you
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show he
is going to be ringside in nine days for
Floyd Mayweather and Conor McGregor on
the Showtime pay-per-view event and
again by early avoid the rush on fight
day Showtime want you to know you can
get it for eighty nine ninety five and
standard depth ten bucks more for
high-def at 9:00 Eastern Time 6:00
Pacific on that day august 26 good to
see you again for a second segment al
Bernstein so um what how do you
categorize this are you in the purest
freak show and wings or what do you
here's the thing about this in most
times a boxing or MMA match up you know
the way the genesis of them is somebody
the promoter or whoever it says oh that
looks really attractive let's put that
out there for people this and you assume
or hope that they'll like it this fight
is more of an organic growth that came
from people wanting it and so they said
well we have to make it and the two
principles obviously it's happening
because the two principles are have a
larger-than-life persona and have this
huge followings and so the fight kind of
came together organically and it is
respectable there's no question about
that it's an event it's a one-off it's
it's something that is happening because
people are curious to see it happen so
you know my my feeling is and now it's
taken on a life of its own and as a
sporting event it's it's providing some
interesting things and you made an
interesting point earlier when we're
doing some things you were saying that
they will touch eight ounce gloves yes
the Nevada Athletic Commission made a
waiver one-time waiver that they can
fight with eight ounce gloves instead of
ten ounce gloves and that was partially
a nod to Conor McGregor because he's
used to fighting with four ounce gloves
in the in MMA so we'll see if that gives
them a help well will it what do you
think that's like you know some people
theorized the other way that Mayweather
who's not a each puncher will benefit
more from having the eighth round eight
ounce gloves I think at the end of the
day if I was McGregor I'd want the eight
ounce gloves so um you know that he
tweeted out thanks Yeti authorities in
karate Avada so we know for being
treating him fairly as the way he got it
we yesterday so we know how he feels
about it yeah and and you know there are
a couple things about this fight from
his standpoint you know Mayweather is
fighting at 154 pounds
Frawley the third time in his career
McGregor's fought at the 155 pound
weight that MMA has ten times he'll be
the bigger stronger man and of course
Mayweather is coming back after a
two-year layoff at age 40 and maybe
where that came back effectively earlier
in his career from two-year layoffs and
was very sharp but forty years old so
those are the things that McGregor's
kind of pinning his hopes on al
Bernstein here on the Rich Eisen show
and I know you cannot make a prediction
you're sitting ringside yeah I like not
to know I know that I look out we go way
back I understand how you are you know
what makes you tick however yes being in
the seat in which I'm residing right now
I must I must then take the back door
yes if you will and play the fill in the
blank yeah we'll win if game with you
which I'm happy to play okay Floyd
Mayweather will win even if there are no
parting gift some hat there are no party
gifts I've got it I'm not even getting
back what I said about this beautiful
studio not even Zee brick or Turtle Wax
those are the old right go ahead chor
Lee press-on nails is another green oh
yeah in the back in the day Wow
so Floyd Mayweather will win if ya
ployed my brother I think will win if he
he can take McGregor into deep waters
and by that I mean McGregor has never
been on his feet on in a match MMA
fights are five rounds and five minutes
and you don't stand the whole time
always if he picks him into the seventh
round that will be longer than McGregor
has ever been on his feet fighting and
McGregor has been known to have some
stamina shoes in the in the MMA matches
although it's a little different and so
I think Mayweather needs to take him
into those middle and late rounds where
he can try to drown him with his hand
speed and combinations and I think
that's his path to victory so McGregor
will win if McGregor will win I add I
did a one of my my videos with Pat
Miletich who's a famous MMA
a champion from days gone by in a great
broadcaster on MMA on access TV and he
he was making the point which is I
subscribed to but he put it this way he
said Makana McGregor has to fight a
dirty fight barely within the rules
in other words be rough with with
Mayweather not when Mayweather's had
problems like when Marcos Maidana fought
Floyd Mayweather and a couple fights ago
in their first fight which I thought was
a draw
Maidana was able to get inside rough up
Floyd push him on the ropes land a lot
of punches making a messy fight earlier
in his career Jose Luis Castillo did the
same thing to him and I thought I
actually won one of their two fights so
McGregor needs to be physical with him
uses the fact that he's going to be the
bigger stronger man he's used to
fighting it this way and roughed him up
as much as you can and then the other
thing is hoping for he's got a really
good left hand can heal and that punch
and Willie hurt Mayweather with it and
that's the way he'd of course bring the
attitude of how he spelled out his
pinstripes on his suit is yes have you
ever seen anything like that no that was
an ER in your mouth the lustrous career
that was a that was completely new I you
know the worst job of anybody during
those those press events probably was
somebody that was working for I don't
know a Hallmark Channel trying to get
sound bites from you know sound bites
from that President had much to use it
was it was interesting al Bernstein here
on the Rich Eisen show you got a
question for me yeah yeah we look at
Floyds career the 49 I know one of the
big criticisms is he kind of ducked guys
when they were at their peak but he does
have the zero so what would a loss do
for Floyd's legacy here
yeah well it's interesting and and the
additional bigger question is how does
the result of this effect either sport
you know for for for boxing well for
Floyd Mayweather legacy wives it's
difficult because even at age 40 you
don't want to lose to to somebody but I
think at the end of the day it won't it
won't ruin what he's done in boxing I
just think people will look at it like
he's 40 years old he came back after a
two-year layoff and he wasn't sharp or
ever though he will take a hit
interestingly the question is what
impact will it have unboxing if that
were to happen if a guy that has only
had amateur fights is able to come in
and beat somebody who even with the
layoffs and the ages acknowledges the
supreme fighter in the sport um what is
you know will and I would like and I
would go back to and Virginia Wade beat
Bobby Riggs in the tennis mats right
Billie Jean King had to come back to
beat Bobby Riggs for the honor of
Kenneth well in some odd way we boxing
could be in that position I think that
the pressures on Mayweather McGregor has
absolutely no pressure here anything
other than a first-round knockout in
which he gets just kick flattened in a
minute and a half everything he does
well in this fight will be gravy for him
and gravy for the UFC I'm trying to
figure out what it is McGregor the
Billie Jean King in that analogy or uh
no oh well I would say McGregor is Bobby
Riggs
okay yeah and then the Virginia Wade is
Mayweather okay did you ever think
everything anyone that come here in
compared on Virginia Wade to that's
clear any whether the Renaissance man
that's why you could do that a couple
more minutes here with al Bernstein in
studio on the Rich Eisen show what's
with Paul Paulie Malignaggi or your
colleague on Showtime what what is
happening well they're do you think is
he aiming for a fight with Conor
McGregor do you think uh pretty pal is a
very rational guy and I think he went
there feeling that he could we just was
going to be helpful and then things got
out of hand um well what got out of hand
I don't well you know I'm not shut up
and talk to Paulie since believe it or
not since all that happens so um it's
just the part where I can take the Fifth
Amendment ha ha well no no it's already
possibly phone-a-friend which which
would be the best place Paulie the
friend is the friend you want me to
raise a thousand percent yes
well look we had Brendan Schaub in that
seat just a couple weeks ago and again
he was conflicted as well because he
like I don't all just like you Yahoo and
I don't know all the details about what
it just seems to me that that that this
is either a a legitimately aggrieved guy
be somebody who didn't realize that he
was the Washington Generals too
to the pop culture of a Globetrotter
named McGregor and see that this is a
dana white concoction to get a fight
between these two guys should McGregor
do what most people expect and that is
to lose to Mayweather it could be any of
the above right that's true I mean it
really could be and I honestly I don't
know because I haven't spoken with them
but but it leaves the thing it did do it
added yet another spark to this to this
well is that it's just like the Super
Bowl in a way that we're we're looking
to fill void with the storylines we are
because it's now nine days until this is
happening
that's what do you know what it what did
you make of Robert Byrd being named as
the other reps also great question Lee
since you point out that McGregor needs
to fight it what a dirty fight within
the rules essentially that's a terrific
question a row Bert Bert is a very
experienced referee who has done he's
done one Mayweather fight in recent
years his fight with Robert Guerrero
that one was an easy one to ref Guerrero
it was there was a little not easy but
you know there wasn't a lot of extra
activity and there of Kenny Bayless who
refereed the second Maidana fight um
received some criticism because he
talked about how he was thinking about
making sure Maidana didn't do things
from the first fight even before he did
him he took some criticism because that
in Kenny's are very fine rent-free so
Robert birds can be a central character
in this fight and both sides agreed on
him he's a very fine official um but
he's going to be really scrutinized does
he let McGregor even work inside how
much does he allow how much does he does
he warn him he's going to be an
important figure than okay are you are
you wearing a tuxedo for the fun believe
it or not know what that's going to
disappoint you is what I mean I
mentioned this in the television only
segment I'll bring it here out that I
got to do fights with you cover fights
with you for the worldwide leader in
sports after Charley Steiner did he
write the omens work for all that time
with you just at the time where ESPN
management said you don't have to wear a
tuxedo and I thought damn it like why am
i covering boxing if I don't get to wear
a tuxedo you were bitterly despise
I was do you know the history of wearing
tuxedos to me I do it happened in the
when boxing was formed in England they
did it a gentlemen's clubs and all the
people in the gyms of the gentlemen's
club where all these got not the same
meaning as today's gentlemen's clubs yes
and I hasten to point out yeah and they
they would all wear tie it would all
wear tuxedos yes and so it became a
tradition later in boxing that ring
announcers and then people doing TV
would wear would wear tuxedos so you're
not wanting to talk to me this is we are
not it tux worthy event oh I I would
agree but you know that we the Showtime
decided that just nice suits would be
the answer Brockman I don't like it now
no you know what L I'm good I think you
should wear one for us maybe I'll see if
I can sneak a tuxedo in for you well
we're not talking about like a dumb and
Dumberer tuxedo no not a blue yeah
something more shirt a little more
tasteful that yeah yeah what we said I
mentioned before we were tuxedos on the
ESPN boxing series the top-ranked boxer
is 48 weeks a year and and I owned when
I was 30 years old I own no tuxedos when
I was 37 year old 737 years old I own 12
tuxedos and I'm like there's something
insane about that because you you know
that and accessories I currently have my
home one hundred and eighty two
different accessories you can succeed oh
you're the worldwide leader in
cummerbund I am yes hey that you know
what I'm going to use that for now and
as a PR marketing to a worldwide leader
in cummerbund I love us al Bernstein
check out again by early avoid the rush
on fight day 89.95 for standard def
99.95 for high def the start time of the
pay-per-view event in nine days is 9:00
Eastern Time can be crazy exciting I
can't wait to watch it love seeing you
look don't be a stranger I'll come back
anytime you want wait please absolutely
I really and thanks for listening to us
in Vegas man yes I'm a staunch listen
okay al Bernstein here John Smoltz still
to come
it is DeNiro 74th birthday will go down
his filmography in a were mole which we
love that's
and still to come the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to